when you think of u.s federal agencies
whose employees are regularly armed the
fbi secret service or department of
homeland security come to mind but the
inflation reduction act which passed the
senate and now requires a vote in the
house could see more guns going to the
irs
about 80 billion dollars is going to the
irs for increased enforcement
operational improvements customer
service and modernizing the agency's
antiquated computer systems
the biggest chunk of the money
45.6 billion dollars will be for
increased enforcement which is a main
goal of democrats after years of
shrinking irs staff and less audit and
collection activity i think people can
fairly expect
a lot more more audits
more
sort of lengthy audits
more serious collection activity i mean
those are things that i think i would
expect i think the enforcement one
is for most people kind of the most
you know the most frightening
because
we don't really know how far it will go
democrats argue the increased investment
is needed to make sure corporations and
high net worth americans are paying what
they owe in taxes after a decade of
declining audit rates but republicans
are sounding the alarm of government
overreach and are concerned to beefed up
irs will lead to more harassment of
small business owners
in response to the irs purchasing nearly
seven hundred thousand dollars worth of
ammunition earlier this year republicans
matt gates and jeff duncan introduced
the disarm the irs act to stop the irs
from buying more bullets
according to a 2017 report from the
government accountability office the irs
had almost 4 500 guns and just over 5
million rounds of ammunition in its
armory but the irs criminal
investigation division which has the
only armed employees at the agency does
not bring that many cases and many
involve more than just taxes a lot of
those kinds of circumstances can be from
not somebody's you know poorly done tax
return or
um you know honest mistakes or even
aggressive tax planning but but rather
from sort of obstructive behavior
uh which the irs i think rightly hates
when somebody's getting audited
and you know lies to the irs or is
getting audited and or or maybe it's a
collection matter owes a lot of money to
the irs
but um you know starts
making kind of a shell game transferring
assets to their brother
you know setting up a foreign company to
hide assets those kinds of things can
clearly be criminal
still the proposed increase which
averages out to about 8.9 billion
dollars a year is a big boost for an
agency whose current annual budget is
just 12.6 billion dollars this likely
means more interactions between the
american public and tax collectors in
the near future we want the system to
work well but on the other hand anyone
you know all of us file tax returns and
everyone
hopes that their tax return is not the
one that's
that's examined and if it is examined
you hope that it's sort of a simple
query and not um you know something that
becomes really protracted and that you
might
you know
characterize as a witch-hunt i mean most
are not that way but
bottom line anytime you talk about a big
slug of money being designated for
you know for irs enforcement
there's going to be worry and i think in
some ways rightly worried
you